professor of astronomy brian keating who
runs the into the impossible podcast
which i recommend you all
check out and subscribe to is there any
test or data that would convince you
that
every uap sighting has a prosaic natural
or scientific
explanation i.e anything that could
falsify the narrative that alien
technology is visiting the earth
so interesting natural or scientific
prosaic explanation and then turns
around and says
i.e disproves some sort of alien
visitation
um i'm not sure the two are mutually
exclusive
i i think you know
i think you can have a discussion about
alien life and still remain scientific
we're doing it now with nasa looking for
microbial life on mars
they're not exclusive you can't say in
one hand you know there's a scientific
explanation
but it's not but it disproves alien life
scientific explanation
may wind up actually proving alienware
if there is so
so i i i think that's f i think that
with all due respect i think that's
false logic uh
i don't i don't know against mr keating
at all i'm sure uh
you know he wants a thorough answer
which i'm going to try to do my best
but the very notion that an alien life
form
can't be scientific look this planet is
probably the greatest ufo that we know
of
right this ball called earth hurtling
through deep space around a you know
obscure star we call the sun and obscure
part of the milky way
has got life all over the place in fact
the birth of science was right here